it's day 25 of the partial government
shutdown President Trump now says he
will never ever back down and one
powerful Senate Republican says there's
nobody on the horse coming to rescue us
one place to see the impact is at the
airport where TSA workers who are not
being paid are often not showing up the
TSA says yesterday's sick calls were up
more than 137 percent compared to a year
ago staff shortages led to long lines at
some airports including the world's
busiest in Atlanta officials there
advise travelers to get themselves three
hours to get through security Kris Van
Cleave is at Washington's Reagan
National Airport Chris good morning good
morning three hours should be an
eye-opener for everyone that would
change the way many people fly and the
TSA here in DC at headquarters remain
very concerned about a national tipping
point moment where what we saw happen in
Atlanta starts popping up at airports
across the country maybe without much
warning what did that look like take a
look at this video from Atlanta very
long lines and wait times over an hour
yesterday that's more than double the
maximum wait time from a week ago as
fewer screening lanes were staffed
because there weren't enough officers to
staff them at George Bush
Intercontinental Airport in Houston the
be terminal checkpoint is closed until
at least Wednesday to free up officers
for checkpoints elsewhere Washington
Dulles had all but one checkpoint closed
for much of the day Monday that was
after a snowstorm left them
short-staffed there now the TSA is
deploying officers from other parts of
the country to Houston and Atlanta to
help cover those sick calls but there's
only so many of those officers to go
around TSA workers will get a one-time
$500 reward for working the holiday
season as early as today there's hope
that buys some time but there's no
question they are feeling the impact of
this shutdown nationally 92 percent of
the workers scheduled to be on the job
yesterday did show up but those sick
calls are starting to have an impact
we're seeing wait times while still in
the normal range performance is ticking
down a little bit still most fliers are
waiting less than 30 minutes Gail all
right most people would not show up
knowing that they weren't going to get
paid so you might want to think about
that special thank you to the people
that do show up on the job
thank you Chris